okay last month
CNN ran with a bombshell of a story
sources with knowledge tell myself and
Carl that Michael Cohen claims that then
candidate Donald Trump knew in advance
about the June 2016 meeting in Trump
Tower in which Russians were expected to
offer his campaign dirt on Hillary
Clinton crucially these sources tell us
that Cohen is willing to make that
assertion to the special counsel robert
muller why is chris chromos head so much
bigger than the other two heads i don't
know why i focus on that
okay well the accompanying article on
their website revealed that quote
contacted by CNN one of Cohen's
attorneys Lanny Davis declined to
comment huh
and just a week ago Lanny Davis Michael
Cohen's attorney doubled down again on
CNN I think
the reporting of this story got mixed up
and in the course of a criminal
investigation we were not the source of
the story okay little problem there he
was lying Lanny Davis was actually the
major source for the entire story he was
also the anonymous source that confirmed
it to other outlets now this week he
came clean telling the Washington Post
that he's not certain the claim is
accurate and that he could not
independently verify it and yesterday he
tells BuzzFeed news that he regrets his
whole role as an independent source in a
subsequent denial of his involvement in
the story look if you could follow that
Davis merely saying he quote made a
mistake but he actually didn't lady
Davis is an old Clinton fixer who has
been spinning information and using the
press to do his bidding for decades now
this was deliberate and the folks at CNN
were only too happy to join him in this
misinformation charade and why because
they have a common enemy
it's Donald J Trump so Davis floats a
malicious and fallacious story to target
a political adversary and the media
gleefully disseminate it now CNN pseudo
and Bernstein delighted in this tale of
trumps misdeeds because it fit the
pathetic Russian narrative that they've
been trying to substantiate for a year
now they used to call CNN remember the
Clinton news network in the day well
with Lanny Davis as an unpaid
contributor it's more fitting than ever
forget 1998 is back but this reminds me
of the disgraced FBI director Jim Comey
we call him James too tall called me
okay fine who planters planted more
stories than Martha Stewart has planted
hydrangeas okay
Comey passed his memos of classified
conversations between himself and the
president to a friend remember that memo
to the file and he did it for media
consumption I understood this to be my
recollection recorded of my conversation
with the president as a private citizen
I felt free to share that I thought it
very important to get it out so why
didn't you give those to somebody
yourself rather than give them through a
third party because I was worried the
media was camping at the end of my
driveway at that point and I was
actually going out of town with my wife
to hide and I worried it would be like
feeding seagulls at the beach so we're
led to believe that he really doesn't
like the press call me while he's
throwing them life-sustaining Chum Oh to
the seagulls and remember these greatest
hits from WikiLeaks Podesta inbox
CNBC's John Harwood sent emails to
Hillary Clinton campaign chairman John
Podesta shamelessly sucking up to him
offering campaign advice and praising
the candidate well he was with her while
he was covering the campaign then there
was Juliet Eilperin of the Washington
Post
she dropped Podesta a line to give him a
heads up on a story she was going to
publish and she included a little
preview so helpful and the New York
Times unbiased Glen thrush he put it in
appearance as well he wrote to Podesta a
story in progress to make sure I'm not
effing anything up he said like Lanny
Davis Podesta was apparently kind of
like a freelance editor for both the
Washington Post and The New York Times
now these are just a few examples of
collusion that we know about only thanks
to WikiLeaks but today we learn from
congressman mark meadows the danger of
this kind of politicization of the media
and partisan story planting he tweeted
in part we've learned new information
suggesting our suspicions are true FBI
DOJ have previously leaked info to the
press and then used those same press
stories as a separate source to justify
thises Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act and meadows then spoke to America's
newsroom following closed-door hearings
with FBI officials
we know that some people at the
Department of Justice and FBI actually
gave information to the media then the
stories were reported then they use
those reports to justify further
investigation now it should be noted
that the FBI tonight is pushing back
hard on this story a source clarified
the agent testified that the FBI
routinely uses media material to
corroborate their work product including
FISA materials but quote never said
directly that we utilize FBI leaks for
Pfizer's boy that was a carefully worded
statement got really parse that one but
with partisans using the media to bait
prosecutors or justify bogus
investigations don't we need to be more
careful and ask more questions I think
America needs journalists that we can
trust but as it stands now we not only
have to worry about the objectivity of
our news sources we have to worry about
their sources as well and that's the
angle